el entrelazamiento cuántico permite que las partículas estén vinculadas sin importar el espacio entre ellas, esto es tan contraintuitivo
que ni siquiera Einstein creía que fuera verdad. en el episodio de hoy de Qiskit en el aula hablaremos sobre cómo el teorema de Bell
demostró que Einstein estaba
equivocado. bienvenido a Qiskit en el aula. en esta serie usaremos Qiskit para explorar algunos conceptos fundamentales que se suelen
cubrir en cursos relacionados con la computación cuántica. cada video también estará acompañado de un módulo interactivo
enlazado en la descripción de abajo, así que asegúrate de revisarlo. en el video de las monedas cuánticas hablamos sobre cómo medir una
superposición cuántica es un proceso intrínsecamente probabilístico, como lanzar una moneda en ciertos aspectos. pero ¿cómo sabemos
esto? ¿podría ser que una partícula cuántica esconda secretamente un resultado predeterminado de una medición pero que de alguna manera no logremos
capturar esa información en nuestra teoría? en los primeros días de la mecánica cuántica esta pregunta fue el tema
de un acalorado debate con dos facciones principales. en un bando estaba Einstein, quien creía que la mecánica cuántica estaba incompleta,
es decir, que le faltaban algunas variables necesarias para describir completamente un sistema. Einstein pensaba que
esas llamadas variables ocultas, si se encontraban, resolverían algunos de los aspectos aparentemente paradójicos y probabilísticos
de la mecánica cuántica. en el otro bando estaba Max Born. Born argumentaba
que la descripción probabilística que da la mecánica cuántica es todo lo que la naturaleza especifica. en otras palabras,
no es solo que no conozcamos el estado de una partícula antes de medirla, es que la partícula no tiene un estado definido
antes de ser medida. durante décadas muchos pensaron que este desacuerdo era una pregunta filosófica que quizás nunca
se resolvería. después de todo, para aprender algo sobre un sistema necesitamos medirlo. ¿cómo podemos aprender
algo sobre la naturaleza de un estado antes de su medición? entonces en 1964 el físico
John Bell encontró una manera. en su artículo Bell examinó las correlaciones estadísticas entre las mediciones de un par de
partículas entrelazadas. si antes de la medición los estados de las partículas estuvieran determinados por alguna variable oculta desconocida,
entonces Bell encontró que sus correlaciones tenían un límite superior. por otro lado, cuando calculó
las correlaciones predichas por la mecánica cuántica, descubrió que violaban ese límite. así que había encontrado una manera de, de una vez
por todas, diferenciar entre la visión de Einstein y la de Born. solo quedaba verificar experimentalmente
esas correlaciones con partículas reales para ver si obedecían la estadística de variables ocultas o si
violaban esa regla. estas pruebas se realizaron con precisión y sofisticación crecientes
a lo largo de los años y son algunos de los experimentos más importantes de la física moderna. fueron tan revolucionarios que
les valieron a tres físicos el Premio Nobel en 2022. pero hoy en día cualquiera puede realizar una
prueba de Bell. todo lo que necesitamos es un poco de conocimiento de Qiskit y acceso a una computadora cuántica de IBM. en este video voy
a explicarte la lógica de la desigualdad de Bell, luego te mostraré cómo podemos poner a prueba las predicciones de Bell en una
computadora cuántica de IBM. la desigualdad de Bell involucra varias mediciones distintas y niveles de lógica, y puede ser
un poco difícil de seguir, pero lo veremos paso a paso y al final valdrá la pena. estamos a punto de demostrar
que el entrelazamiento es real y que Einstein estaba equivocado. eso no es algo que mucha gente pueda decir que ha hecho. así que aquí está
lo que Bell propuso. digamos que tienes una forma de producir muchas copias de un par de partículas entrelazadas. físicamente,
estos pares podrían producirse mediante un proceso de desintegración donde una partícula se desintegra en dos. si viste el video sobre
el experimento de Stern-Gerlach, sabes que las partículas pueden tener un momento angular intrínseco llamado
espín. digamos que una partícula de espín cero se desintegra en dos partículas de espín 1/2.
entonces cada una de las partículas de espín 1/2 puede medirse con espín más 1/2 o menos
1/2, también llamado espín arriba o espín abajo. pero dado que se desintegraron de una partícula de espín cero, las dos deben combinarse para
tener un espín total de cero también. por lo tanto, si una se mide como arriba la otra debe ser
abajo y viceversa. estas partículas forman un par entrelazado que luce así.
así que si una se mide como arriba, la otra es abajo y viceversa. digamos que la partícula uno vuela hacia la izquierda, o
en la dirección menos X, donde un investigador al que llamaremos Lucas mide su
espín. luego la partícula dos vuela de manera similar hacia la derecha,
donde otra investigadora, Rihanna, puede medir ese espín. Lucas y Rihanna pueden independientemente
rotar sus dispositivos de medición para elegir medir el espín de sus respectivas partículas en cualquier dirección
perpendicular a la dirección de movimiento de la partícula. si enviamos muchas copias del estado entrelazado a Lucas
y Rihanna, pueden recopilar estadísticas de medición. si siempre miden a lo largo del mismo eje, estas estadísticas no
serán muy interesantes: cada vez que uno mida espín arriba el otro medirá espín abajo, y cada vez que uno mida espín
hacia adelante el otro medirá espín hacia atrás, y así sucesivamente. pero si los dos investigadores miden a lo largo de ejes diferentes, podemos encontrar
algo más interesante. démosle a Lucas y Rihanna tres ejes a lo largo de los cuales
medir. llamaremos a estos ejes a, b y c, y están separados entre sí por
120°. la pregunta que haremos con este experimento es: si Lucas y Rihanna son libres de medir a lo largo de cualquiera de los tres
ejes, ¿con qué frecuencia obtendrán los dos el mismo signo? claramente, si Lucas y Rihanna miden a lo largo del mismo eje,
digamos el eje a, nunca podrán obtener el mismo signo, ya que las partículas deben combinarse para tener espín cero. pero cuando eligen
ejes diferentes, ¿cómo se correlacionarán sus mediciones, si es que lo hacen? según Einstein, esta descripción cuántica
del estado de la partícula está incompleta. él pensaba que deben existir variables ocultas que
predeterminen el resultado de todas las posibles mediciones de espín, ya que sin eso las partículas entrelazadas tendrían que
de alguna manera comunicarse el resultado de su medición la una a la otra de manera instantánea. si una se mide como
arriba allá lejos, la otra debe saber instantáneamente que es abajo aquí
cerca. estas variables ocultas podrían ser cualquier conjunto complicado de instrucciones para el resultado de los experimentos, pero el punto es
que el estado de espín de cada partícula por separado está determinado, así que no es necesaria ninguna comunicación.
experimentalmente eso significaría que las mediciones hechas por Lucas no tendrían ningún efecto en la partícula de Rihanna y viceversa.
esto podría poner ciertos límites en qué tan correlacionadas pueden estar las dos mediciones. según Born, sin embargo, este estado
es todo lo que se puede decir sobre el par de partículas antes de la medición, por lo que la medición de una partícula
afecta el resultado de la medición del otro; esto puede tener distintas implicaciones para las correlaciones entre mediciones. Veamos cómo cada
teoría afecta estas correlaciones. En el tratamiento de variables ocultas existe un conjunto secreto de instrucciones previo a la
medición que ya determina lo que Lucas medirá a lo largo de cada uno de los tres ejes. Por ejemplo, estas
instrucciones podrían ser positivas si Lucas mide a lo largo del eje a,
positivas si mide a lo largo de b, y negativas si mide a lo largo de c. Podemos
escribir esto como más a, más b y menos c. Entonces la partícula de Rihanna
necesitaría tener las variables menos a, menos b y más c para asegurar que el
espín total a lo largo de cualquier dirección sea cero.
Hay ocho conjuntos de instrucciones posibles que satisfacen esta restricción de espín cero, así que cada vez que se envía un nuevo par de
partículas a Lucas y Rihanna, podría contener cualquiera de estos ocho conjuntos de instrucciones. Ahora queremos
determinar, asumiendo que las partículas contienen uno de los conjuntos secretos de instrucciones dados en la tabla, y
asumiendo que Lucas y Rihanna eligen de forma independiente cuál de los tres ejes medir, ¿cuál es la
probabilidad de que ambos midan el mismo signo? Si las instrucciones son las de las filas 1 o
8, entonces claramente esta probabilidad es cero, ya que las dos partículas tendrán signos opuestos sin importar sus
ejes de medición. Pero ¿qué pasa con las instrucciones de la fila dos? Medirían el mismo signo si
Rihanna mide a lo largo de c y Lucas mide a lo largo de a o b, o si Lucas
mide a lo largo de c y Rihanna mide a lo largo de a o b. Eso son cuatro de las nueve
combinaciones posibles de medición que darán a Lucas y Rihanna el mismo signo. Si hacemos esto para
cada conjunto de instrucciones, verás que las filas 3 a 7 también dan una probabilidad de 4/9. Esto significa que si
Einstein tiene razón y variables ocultas como estas predeterminan el resultado de las mediciones, no hay forma de que Lucas
y Rihanna midan el mismo signo con una probabilidad mayor a 4/9. Esta es la desigualdad de Bell: P menor o
igual a 4/9. Y como mostraremos, las partículas entrelazadas la violan. Así que para
ver qué predice la mecánica cuántica, digamos que Lucas mide a lo largo de a. Pueden ocurrir dos cosas: o mide espín arriba, entonces
Rihanna mediría espín abajo a lo largo de a, o mide espín abajo y Rihanna mediría espín arriba a lo largo de a. Pero
queremos la probabilidad de que Rihanna mida el mismo signo que Lucas a lo largo de cualquier eje que ella elija, no solo a. Si
ella mide a lo largo de b o c, se complica un poco. Resulta que
si sabes lo que Rihanna medirá con un 100% de certeza a lo largo de una dirección, puedes calcular las probabilidades
de que ella mida arriba o abajo a lo largo de cualquier otro eje con un poco de geometría.
Si tu estado siempre mide espín arriba a lo largo de un eje, entonces la probabilidad de medir espín arriba a lo largo de un eje diferente
será igual al cuadrado del coseno de la mitad del ángulo entre los dos ejes. Es un poco complicado, pero
te mostraré a qué me refiero. Si Lucas mide espín arriba a lo largo de a, sabemos con un 100% de certeza que Rihanna mediría
espín abajo si midiera a. Podemos representar eso con un vector
como este. En este caso, los ángulos entre este vector y los otros dos ejes de medición b y c son ambos
60°, así que la mitad de eso es 30°, y el coseno de
30 es el que se muestra aquí. El coseno al cuadrado de
30° es igual a 3/4. Ahora, ¿qué pasa si Lucas mide espín abajo
a lo largo de a? Sabemos que Rihanna mediría espín arriba a lo largo de a, así que podemos dibujar otro vector aquí. Ahora
este vector que representa este conocimiento está a 120° de cada uno de los otros dos ejes b
y c, así que podemos aplicar el mismo truco geométrico, pero esta vez obtendremos el coseno de
60°. Así que el coseno al cuadrado de
60° es igual a 1/4. Como Lucas tiene igual probabilidad de
medir espín arriba y espín abajo a lo largo de a, necesitamos promediar estas dos probabilidades de Rihanna y obtenemos una
probabilidad final de que Rihanna mida el mismo signo que Lucas de 1/2. Entonces P
igual a 1/2 es mayor que 4/9, así que la desigualdad de Bell se viola.
Eso significa que mientras las reglas de la mecánica cuántica se cumplan, las variables ocultas son imposibles. Ahora podemos usar Qiskit y una
computadora cuántica de IBM para poner a prueba la desigualdad de Bell con mediciones cuánticas reales. Podemos mapear los estados de espín arriba y
espín abajo de las partículas de Lucas y Rihanna a los estados cero y uno de los qubits en la computadora cuántica. Usaremos
dos qubits: uno para representar la partícula de Lucas y otro para la de Rihanna, y los entrelazaremos con este circuit cuántico.
Los dos qubits están representados por los dos cables q0 y q1, y esta combinación
de gates X, Hadamard y CNOT creará el mismo estado entrelazado que teníamos entre las partículas de Lucas y Rihanna. Ahora
necesitamos medir cada qubit. Estableceremos la medición de Lucas a lo largo de a, que diremos es el eje Z. Luego la medición de Rihanna
puede ser a lo largo de a, b o c, así que necesitaremos tres circuits separados para cada uno de estos tres casos. Pero en este
video solo haremos uno. Puedes ir al módulo vinculado en la descripción para ver el ejemplo completo. Si Rihanna mide a lo largo de
b, entonces nuestro circuit se ve así, donde ry es una rotación de 120° para cambiar
el eje de medición de Rihanna. Podemos usar el Primitive sampler de Qiskit para ejecutar este experimento muchas veces y recopilar
estadísticas de las mediciones resultantes. Las dos columnas 0 0 y 1 1 representan los casos en que Lucas y
Rihanna midieron el mismo signo, que es lo que buscamos. Así que la probabilidad de medir ambas partículas con el
mismo signo es casi 1/2. Esto viola la desigualdad de Bell. Esto significa
que las dos partículas están entrelazadas: cada una parece saber instantáneamente el resultado de la
medición de la otra. Todavía hay cierto desacuerdo sobre cómo interpretar exactamente esto.
el entrelazamiento y lo que ocurre cuando mides un estado entrelazado, pero estas preguntas son más filosóficas.
La teoría es bastante innegable a estas alturas: el entrelazamiento es definitivamente real, y lo sabemos gracias a Bell, su
desigualdad y los muchos físicos que han realizado experimentos para ponerla a prueba. Si te gustaría contarte entre esos
físicos y realizar tu propia prueba de Bell con una computadora cuántica, asegúrate de visitar el módulo de la desigualdad de Bell
vinculado en la descripción. Gracias por ver y nos vemos la próxima vez.